Welcome back everyone is going to be my new
dune trailer video.
They finally dropped the main regular trailer
even though we got one a long time ago.
Last year it seems like it's been 84 years
since we've heard about this movie but is
coming out October 22.
Of course will be doing videos for so be sure
to subscribe to get everything is a whole
bunch of Easter eggs here.
So we'll break it all down.
The new trailer opens with Zendaya's Chani
narrating a she's speaking up all treaties
in the visions that he's having he talks about
this later in the trailer to I been having
dreams about this girl on Arrakis the whole
thing is that he doesn't realize that he's
having visions of the future.
He just thinks of their dreams right now early
in the movie.
The reason why they probably open with her
during this is because you barely saw her
in the last trailer.
Because the way they're pacing the story out
between the first couple of movies she's not
in the first movie quite as much she's in
the second movie.
But all explained in a second if you know
the story of doing if you watch that 1984
Dune movie that David Lynch one that you understand
why she doesn't really become a big character
till much later in the story and the big difference
in this new do movie is that they're basically
breaking the first two books up rest the David
Lynch movie combine the first two books and
had to speedrun the story.
So that is not speed running things quite
as much during this new version of the film franchise
But when she's talking about outsiders ravaging
Arrakis for its spice their mostly showing
you house harkonnens men and the beast Rabban attacking the fremen and and some of the
attack from the betrayal later in the movie,
they don't distinguish too much.
But you get the idea the harkonnens have been
ruling over Arrakis in managing spice production
for the Empire for a long time, so the most
of the massacre that you see play out over
the course the trailer is from the betrayal
later in the movie doing stuff like this to
the locals for a long time, the baron basically
gave control of the operation to the Beast
Rabban in the beast is an animal played by
Dave Batista as you can see he's very apt
casting there.
He's going to wreck everyone during the movie.
But the way they cut the footage Timothee
Chalamet's Paul wakes up in bed on Caladan
as if he's just heard Chani talking to him
saying these things he doesn't really gained
the ability to actually see the future perfect
visions of the future till later when he takes
the water of life.
Once he actually takes the water of life and
becomes the Kwisatz Haderach that's when he
becomes the super being any can see perfectly
into the future that might be around the time
where they in the first movie with him taking
the water of life and unlocking those powers.
If you remember the original film the sleeper
has awakened.
But even though he becomes the Kwisatz Haderach
if someone in the sisterhood takes the water
of life in it doesn't kill them.
It unlocks perfect press scenes in a bunch
of other powers like they gain full access
the entire genetic memory of thousands of
years of the sisterhood to become this all-knowing,
all seeing person.
But when members of the sisterhood become
Reverend mother's they also take the water of life
They don't become quite as powerful as Atredies
becomes because he's the product of this big
genetic breeding program that's been going
on for a long long time.
It gives them a fractional amount of the powers
the Paul gets at the beginning the movie here
they're still on how to trade his former homeworld
of Caliban, which is a very green water based planet
In stark contrast to the deserts of Arrakis
that's why the headboard on his bed is covered
with all those fish the funny foreshadowing
thereto though is that eventually through
his powers and influence over Arrakis is a
slow the planet eventually turns back into
more of a habitable environment.
But it's to the detriment of the sand worms
that themselves are the source of the spice
the so critical to the rest of the universe.
But that's not to like the way way way later
in the story.
Hopefully looking through children of Dune
God Emperor of Dune some of the later books
if things are successful enough in it sounds
like this new movie is going to do pretty well
Then they show you Paul meeting up with Duncan
Idaho played by Jason Imola earlier in the
movie before they left caladan Duncan is the
house atreides swordsman you actually do get
to see him do some really good sword work
and fight scenes all these fights that he
has later in the trailer that's from the betrayal.
But he also becomes Duke Leto's ambassador
to the from an early in the movie when they
first to control the Rakas from house Harkonnen.
Duke Leto had hoped to win over the from and
people as the natives of Arrakis because of
what happened to them under house Harkonnen
in rule also because he very truly felt like
the frame and knew a lot about the secrets
of Arrakis that the rest of the universe did not know
So Duncan is only here for a little while
early in the movie, then he comes back later
after he's been with the from and for a long
time and also when Paul and lady Jessica escape
after the betrayal into the desert.
Duncan is the one that offers them sanctuary
with the from and but early in the movie Paul
is just telling Duncan about his visions of
the future of this girl that he sing on Arrakis
which he doesn't really understand yet.
The whole reason why he has these abilities
though, is because he's part of this genetic
breeding program for the sisterhood have been
orchestrating for a long time hoping to create
a series of alliances through marriage to
eventually create a lasting peace between
house Harkonnen and and house atreides and
eventually much, much later down the timeline.
Like way off in the future eventually create
a Kwisatz Haderach being that the sisterhood
could use to sort of exert more influence
in the universe in the Empire already a very
powerful organization in the Empire but if
they were able to control their own Kwisatz
Haderach who would do what they say, then
they would be the greatest power in the universe.
But earlier in the timeline here their whole
plan was for lady Jessica pulls mother to
give Duke Leto a daughter and when that daughter
to one of Baron Harkonnen and sons and use
that as a way to create peace between their
two houses, because when the story picks up
at the beginning of the movie.
There's a lot of tension within the land straw.
Which is basically like the group of noble
houses in the universe that rule over the
universe, the Duke is become really popular
really powerful.
They develop this new military fighting technique
called the wearing way.
So the Emperor is really afraid that the Duke
will try to depose him, eventually this been
a long standing feud between house Harkonnen
in and house atreides some of the story picks
up in the movie the conflict between the three
of them, the baron the Emperor in the Duke
is sort of boiling over, but also on top of
that, because Paul descendent from the sisterhood
and he took the water of life that's why he
was able to become the Kwisatz Haderach if
you been any other normal person intake in
the water of life it would've just killed
them like normal people can't take the water
of life watching the early part of the trailer here
If you see the 1984 Dune movie a lot of this
should look familiar.
Paul being trained by gurney Halleck played
by Josh Brolin in the weird in way the special
sonic weaponry the house atreides develops.
It gives them a huge advantage in combat they
can use it to kill like this way says in the
original movie kill with the word they can
also use it for defense.
So eventually way later in the movie after
the betrayal.
And Paul and lady Jessica join the from and
it seems that we actually see footage of him
training them in them assaulting the Harkonnen
and's using his new fighting techniques.
This scene might look a little bit different.
But it's the same scene of the Reverend mother
from the original movie coming to test Paula
treaties in the counterpart to test if he's
an animal or human the whole ideas they want
to test them to see if he's going to turn
into a monster.
There's not sure what he's going to become
they just know that because he dissents from
the sisterhood there is the potential for
him to gain some of their powers.
So they're kind of worried about that.
So if you were to fail the test eventually
they would just have them killed is the process
of using nerve conduction to create the sensation
of pain when they do it to Paul they're so
afraid that he's going to turn into a monster
that they crank it way up and they give him
way more pain than anyone has ever been able
to withstand before then you hear Duke Leto
treaties played by Oscar Isaac discussing
their plan to bring peace to Arrakis at the order of the emperor
secretly this is obviously a trap set by the Emperor
who's working with house Harkonnen and to
get rid of the Duke and cripple house atreides,
then the intercut the montage of a bunch of
different scenes of Paul actually meeting
Chani on Arrakis later in the story and they
want you to see him having these visions of
everything bad.
That's about to happen.
This is Baron Harkonnen and played by stolen
scars guard all these explosions are probably
from the betrayal later in the film everything
going crazy later in the movie.
This is when they first arrive on arrakis
and enter the fortress formally occupied by
house Harkonnen and they should is the beast.
Men torturing all these people as gurney back
on Caladan earlier in the movie is trying
to prepare Paul before they left listen to
thanos he's not lying.
The beast is brutal this is the new version
of doctor yueh he's an imperial trained physician
working for the Dukes family the black diamond
in his forehead is just the mark of his Imperial
conditioning given to him during his training
as a doctor, he is obviously a huge part of
the betrayal later in the film.
Even though the emperors kind of pulling the
strings behind all this the whole time is
actually the Harkonnen is the took his family
in her using extortion and torture to get
them to betray the Duke and his family.
We had way more footage the Baron and after
he says kill them all this footage from the
actual Harkonnen and attack during the betrayal
itself.
Then as Paul questions his future.
What is going to become earlier in the movie
talking to his father, the Duke they cut it
with the footage of the sand worm sort of
bowing to him later in the movie after he
and Jessica have escaped to the desert in
the sand.
Worms can also sense who he is what is about
to become you also notice the design of the
sand worms is very different from the original
film the production design of the movie just
in general looks amazing a lot of it's inspired
by the original concept art from the Dune
books the try to be a little bit more accurate
to the look that was described in the original
books this fight with Paul is happening really
early after Duncan first offers them sanctuary
with the from and right after they've escape
to the desert that looks a we actually get
see Paul, leading some raids on the Harkonnen
and later in the movie after he's been living
with the from and for a while but before he's
taken the water of life.
Like after he joins the from and he starts
to train them in the secret house atreides
battle techniques them when lady Jessica says
it's time at the end.
That's a reference to a couple different things.
But the way they use it in the trailer.
They want you to think that it's a reference
to him taking the water of life and truly
becoming the Kwisatz Haderach so like I said
that might be around the time where they in
this first new film, but they basically have
the whole next film planned out if you seen
the original David Lynch Dune movie, basically
they do the story.
The second book, which is the rest the story
of that film the movies, out October 22.
Both on HBO Max and on theaters in the same
day.
So if you are able I would recommend that
you see this on the biggest screen possible.
If you spotted any big Easter eggs or references
during the trailer that I didn't mention the
video just right them below in the comments.
This is obviously just the beginning.
Is this whole big story very much every big
science fiction story including Star Wars
borrows a lot of inspiration from the original
Dune book series is the same way the a lot
of modern fantasy stories borrow from talking
and the Lord of the rings books.
I believe they're supposed to be a new Spider-Man
no way home trailer sometime relatively soon
and a new venom let there be carnage trailer
so make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel so
you don't miss anything.
Everyone click here for that brand-new Loki
season 2 teaser and all the deleted scenes
of Kang and click here for all my Loki episode
videos.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys tonight!